intelligence is one of those terms that
causes quite the turmoil within society
but also within ourselves from a very
young age each person is raised to
perceive intelligence as probably the
most critical factor that will determine
his or her well-being the truth however
is that the way intelligence is
portrayed and eventually interpreted
leads to a myriad of issues that every
generation needs to face most of us tend
to think of intelligence as this elusive
skill that characterizes people who have
achieved a great deal of success in
their lifetime or managed to solve
seemingly insoluble problems moreover
the overwhelming majority of social
agents believe strongly that
intelligence is an innate trait that has
no plasticity and that each individual
needs to make peace with the idea that
their intelligence will remain unchanged
throughout their lives this
controversial belief always bugged me in
that once one accepts his or her own
limitations he or she agrees to a very
limited and limiting version of reality
a version that not only reinforces the
unquestionable struggle that encompasses
the human condition but also in some
cases imposes a layer of misery upon
one's life that makes a struggle almost
impossible to bear despite my adherence
to pragmatism as one of the main tenets
that characterize my world view i
couldn't just charitably accept such a
debatable truism over the past five
years i have undergone a transformation
with regards to the way i view and most
importantly understand the essence and
applicability of intelligence i achieved
that through a process of immersion in
skills that require a lot of cognitive
effort but
also by being an astute observer of the
underlying narratives within the social
ecosystems that i inhabited this process
allowed me to conduct careful inquiries
into the actual functions of
intelligence and thereby engineer an
effective way to deal with the
conundrums posed by its complicated
nature this video constitutes an attempt
from my side to illustrate my belief
that intelligence is a very malleable
concept and that once properly construed
can change one's life in monumental ways
in one of my favorite making sense
podcasts titled complexity and stupidity
sam harris invited the biologist david
krakauer to discuss information complex
systems and the future of humanity at
one point harris asks krakauer to offer
his own definition of intelligence he
does so in a lengthy way but i assure
you this is one of the most potent
definitions you will ever encounter if i
sat down with an extraordinary
mathematician and i said i can't solve
that equation
and they say well no it's easy here this
is what you do and you look at it you
say oh yes it is easy right you made
that look easy
that's what we mean when we say someone
is smart they make things look easy
if on the other hand i sat down with
someone who was incapable and they just
kept you know dividing by two you know
for whatever reason uh i said what on
earth are you doing what a stupid thing
to do you'll never solve the problem you
know what a what a foolish thing to do
what a
inefficient thing to do right so
that is what we mean by intelligence uh
it's it's the thing that we do that
ensures that the problem
is very efficiently solved
and
in a way that makes it appear effortless
and stupidity is a set of rules that we
use to ensure that the problem will be
solved in longer than chance or never
right um and and is nevertheless uh
pursued with alacrity and enthusiasm
in essence what krakauer suggests is
that intelligence is the ability of
humans to innovate with regards to the
way they approach problem solving one of
the most important cognitive tools
humans have come up with in order to
make problem solving more effectual is
education and the transference of
knowledge in a way our intelligence is
predicated upon our capacity to embrace
novelty and change if you consider that
most of the people society portrays as
intelligent that is usually academics
scientists and entrepreneurs you will
notice that a certain pattern can be
identified most of these people are high
in traits openness and conscientiousness
which is roughly translated as a
proclivity towards new information and
the methodical adoption of this
information the substrate of our social
edifice is formed in accordance with our
capacity to deal with new information
and evolve ourselves to the degree that
we are capable of converting information
into something valuable evolution itself
adheres to this fundamental principle
and throughout our history we have used
it as a means to the betterment of our
living conditions evidently intelligence
can be summarized as the ability of
humans to push the envelope of
conventional wisdom and push back
against everything that impedes their
progress intelligent people are in a
sense the pioneers of knowledge creation
iq is one of those subjects that can
lead to quite heated debates especially
due to the recent racial issues that
emerged in modern america my view on the
topic has always been open since i have
not yet encountered an all-encompassing
theory that can offer a canonical
interpretation of how iq is related to
achievement well-being and social impact
yes iq is an important factor when
determining the aptitude of an
individual to process information fast
and also engage in complex problems but
iq can by no means be used as a panacea
whenever we try to have a fruitful
dialogue about what constitutes
intelligence and intelligent behavior in
that nebulous landscape many
contemporary thinkers have attempted to
offer their own interpretation with
regards to how iq is molding the fabric
of society charles mary for instance
after publishing the infamous bell curve
argued that iq is substantially
influenced by both inherited and
environmental factors and that it is a
better predictor of many personal
dynamics including financial income job
performance birth out of wedlock and
involvement in crime than an
individual's parental socioeconomic
status this assertion has caused the
hyperbolic backlash from many
progressive and liberal groups since it
creates an uneven dichotomy when it
comes to evaluating the impact of iq
compared to that of the environment
although mari was speaking in averages
and his samples were taken in the 80s
and can't under any circumstances be
characterized as exhaustive he raises
some interesting points such as iq is
heritable apparently no less than 40
percent and no more than 80 percent iq
scores are stable although not perfectly
so over much of a person's life there is
such a difference as a general factor of
cognitive ability on which human beings
differ if you ever take an iq test you
will realize that what it attempts to
measure is more or less your ability to
process information quickly and
understand certain patterns within a
system some iq advocates suggest that iq
remains relatively stable over a
person's lifespan and some others argue
that based on studies researchers have
noticed major fluctuations in iq points
after tracking people for several years
my personal experience has shown that
over the years and after taking many
tests my average iq has raised
significantly and i can attribute that
to many factors ranging from my ability
to focus better to my being able to feel
accustomed with the general principles
of an iq test and also my
multi-disciplinary approach to knowledge
acquisition whatever the case i can say
for sure how much of a critical factor
iq can be in determining the
intelligence of an individual david
krakauer in his interview with sam
harris asserts that iq is measuring
mainly working memory and that if you
subject individuals to deliberate
practice regimes you can witness them
acquiring skills that seem extraordinary
so evidence is gravitating towards the
side of plasticity and not of that of
innate aptitude
before i explain the relationship
between memory and intelligence let's
devote a couple of sentences to explain
how memory actually works back in the
day people used to think that memory is
like a filing cabinet full of individual
memory folders in which information is
stored away today scientific consensus
suggests that memory is a far more
complicated apparatus in that it is
located not in one particular place in
the brain
but is instead a brain-wide process the
following image illustrates which areas
in the brain are responsible for the
storage of different memories as you can
see in order to recall a specific memory
your brain needs to process information
in a way that different systems will
work synergistically to provide cohesive
thought the closest we have come to
connect the terms memory and
intelligence is via the term
crystallized intelligence coined by
psychologist raymond bernard cattell
crystallized intelligence refers to
cognitive functions associated with
previously acquired knowledge in
long-term store that is the ability to
use learned knowledge and experience
despite the fact that there are inborn
variations in humans when certain
practices get applied memory can be
hacked studies have shown that via
learning techniques like mnemonics
people can make use of elaborative
encoding retrieval cues and imagery as
specific tools to encode any given
information in a way that allows for
efficient storage and retrieval during
university i used to employ a specific
technique i called the rule of three to
allow me to remember ways to solve
different math problems i used to write
down the solution of a problem after
understanding its mechanics on a piece
of paper slowly and deliberately i did
that three times in a row this process
almost magically helped me recall the
solution effortlessly during an exam my
main point here is under no
circumstances to degrade the notion and
importance of memory but to question
ubiquitous assumptions that memory is
one of the holy grails of intelligence
there is also a critique of the
prevailing tactics of the current
educational system that focuses mainly
on the promotion of road memorization
instead of creative thinking
if you come to think about it smart
people are perceived as smart because of
their ability to make difficult things
look easy the universe is a very
elaborate and complex system and it is
this complexity that requires us to be
smarter the smarter we become the better
we will be able to identify and
eventually exploit regularities in a
random and complex environment our
history a species is a prescient story
of survival adversity and prosperity
that hinges on how persistent we are in
reinventing our strategy towards
complexity such a perennial struggle
might seem intolerable for most of us
but the truth is that if we don't
embrace it and eventually internalize it
it will persist and intensify as i
mentioned earlier the current status quo
doesn't really favor innovative
approaches to our current predicament
the modern education system is operating
more like a worker factory than it is as
a knowledge cultivation hub contrarian
approaches need to be nurtured both on a
personal but also on a family and
eventually community level if we ever
want to escape the maladies of modern
education persistent reliance on
erroneous practices
is a recipe for disaster that will only
result in further stagnation it is
imperative to create a pedagogical
schema that helps people embrace
uncertainty and provoke conventional
thinking to the best of my knowledge
such ambitious endeavors can't be
expected to come to fruition overnight
they require systematic adherence to a
certain knowledge framework that is
comprised of the following parameters
artistic appreciation and that is the
realization that there is truth in art
and that the capacity of the individual
to explore and understand the underlying
truth in art
reinforces their capacity to think in an
intelligent way
multi-disciplinary thinking
that is the immersion in various
disciplines in an attempt to formulate a
more holistic interpretation of the
world around us innovative technologies
that is the ability to keep up with new
trends in technology the rejection of
technology as a tool for solely
entertainment purposes and the
realization that technology will enact
monumental changes in monolithic
structures within society that
previously seemed impossible
philosophical and psychological
awareness that is the comprehension and
the eventual
of major philosophical and psychological
concepts that can aid their eyes of
self-awareness mind and body connection
that is the realization that mind and
body are interconnected systems that
need to operate synergistically and that
the negligence of the one will impede
the growth of the other proper
understanding of history and national
identity that is the adoption of the
belief that history is a place where
multifarious lessons can be extracted
and that these lessons can offer
important guidance to the way the
individual understands his or her roots
in closing i am going to engage in a
controversial comment whenever you
notice people exhibiting non-intelligent
behavior although iq memory and
upbringing may play their role i
strongly believe that the
non-intelligent behavior is primarily a
byproduct of the mental and physical
space they decided to inhabit the
disposition of humans to blend in in
order to avoid ostracism can generate a
contradiction between what they actually
believe and how they manifest what they
believe into words and deeds leading to
what we perceive as non-intelligent
behavior such a space generates
parochial attitudes antithetical to the
mere nature of intelligence thus
recycling behaviors and mindsets toxic
for the flourishing of an individual
what keeps feeding my optimism though is
that the internet has helped voices that
were afraid to express contrarian
viewpoints in the past
to do so nowadays without fear even if
some of them are anonymous for me this
is the only cure for non-intelligent
behavior to empower the individual to
such a degree that they can understand
that their intelligence can only
flourish when they embrace personal
responsibility pursue freedom and are
contrarian whenever the situation
demands it history is the greatest
school and history has shown that only
contrarians can turn the tide
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon adrian out
you